foreign
I've been with this girl for about three
years I don't know if I should leave but
over the last year or so she's been very
controlling I'm not allowed to hang out
with friends because she doesn't have
her family or her friends in the state
it's hard man I'm sorry
[Music]
yo yo what's up this is John with the Dr
John deloney show
show about your marriage and your mental
health and parenting and relationships
whatever is going on in your life we're
here to walk alongside you figure it out
together if you want to be on the show
you got real things going on in your
life
and you want to be
I don't know yeah pretty brave pretty
strong just to lay it out there for the
world and what you're working through
give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 and just know that
whatever you're going through other
people are going through it too and when
you got the courage to come up and say
hey this is happening to me in my life
I'm looking for some ideas and Direction
and wisdom on where to go next
countless other people countless other
people are going to benefit from your
courage so give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 leave a message or go to
John deloney.com ask ask hey Kelly this
past weekend we had a wild uh
live event there was I don't know
two thousand two twenty five hundred
people there was it was a it was a mad
house but for the first time it was so
awesome
we had long signing lines and when I say
long signing lines they were long
signing lines and
you're you're a straight up celebrity
so I was I kid you not and I'm not being
um
I'm not exaggerating when I say
easily a hundred times probably closer
to 125 times was asked about my tattoos
that's what everybody wants to ask me
about
I love it Hey where's your tattoos can
you can I see your tattoos yeah so on
Friday each of the producers had to get
on the stage and talk about their show
so I get up there and I'm standing there
we haven't even started talking yet we
haven't even the host that's
interviewing me hasn't even said
anything yet first thing somebody else
out show us your tattoos no no they
didn't they yelled show us your tats
and I on stage was like what is
happening and
then you answered like oh John always
talked about tattoos and I was like oh
because I have these ear things in
I was like no way is that how somebody's
gonna talk to Kelly like I'll I'm gonna
go to jail and the show hadn't even
started anyway it was awesome it was it
was so much
to talk to our we have some amazing
listeners I'm telling you it was
it was like so often I do this show and
then I drive home
and all by myself
and I I literally asked myself this
exact question what are you doing with
your life like what do you there's
nobody here like we're just talking into
the void and then to see his signing
lines for an hour like for there was
hundreds of people it was like I was
insane and everybody's got a story
everybody's changing something
everybody's working through something
everybody's looking at you and being
like I don't know how you do it every
day I got a lot of that too like oh my
God how do you do it thank you so much
we're so glad I heard over and over and
over you
children I'm sorry Kelly I'm so
I have to go to work and be a babysitter
too it was it was incredible it was
awesome it really was it was so much fun
and in related news so imagine this
you're doing a live radio show in front
of a couple thousand people
the music starts playing all of the
Affiliates across the country 600 plus
Affiliates are gearing up for this show
and I co-host uh the Ramsay show with
Dave Ramsey
and one of the main pieces of equipment
goes down
and
we don't know it we're on stage looking
all Smiley and shiny and we've got
makeup on like goofballs and we're like
we're just ready to rock and roll we're
doing it
and behind the scenes the engineers Nate
Dogg Andrew these guys are just
duct taping things together and keeping
this thing going and it did miss a beat
but when we got back you get to see
everybody was just slumped up against
the wall like all of the work it took to
manually do this stuff Andrew you saved
the day dude
big time man
made it we made it and it's a lot easier
doing that than your show generally
well played well hey not because of that
but because we love you
um we got together and everybody pitched
in and finally we got your daughter a
bed
and our friends at dreamcloud are gonna
send her a brand new uh twin mattress
for her and so we're gonna take care of
y'all and get y'all squared up I know
your daughter's been sleeping out in the
garage because in the dog bed in the dog
bed because you're vying for father of
the year but
um we just want you to know we love you
and
man those little those things add up so
fast man so fast I think our friends at
dream Cloud for for hooking you up it's
awesome
and uh cool all right let's roll out to
y'all can't see this Andrew's blushing
he's a man of very few words you're
handsome you're a handsome blusher all
right let's go to
um
Tejas let's go to Carlos in San Antonio
como estas Carlos
good how are you good man
life going okay
uh been better but it's going all right
so what's up dude
uh so I am having issues with my family
uh I put up some boundaries with them
try to be as clear as possible because
it seem like they're
respecting them and I'm kind of at the
point where I'm wondering if it's a
relationship I should come out of my
life
oh man
so tell me about it
wow okay 35. all right so tell me about
it
yeah so uh growing up kind of like
turbulent household uh older brother has
some behavioral issues like uh um
diagnosed behavioral issue issues uh
family did the best they could uh
definitely chemical had some impact on
me with like cops being called the house
constantly
um yelling kind of like a turbulent
household uh fast forward College the
house took a little bit of a breather
from everybody and realized that it
wasn't really a healthy environment
where everybody was come leaning on me
to be the normal kind of crowding
mechanism and I was the child it was the
youngest person in the house like good
margin
um and I need to kind of let's not take
that weight on uh and fast forward to
mid-30s now and
older brother has a kid uh kind of in
this weird Cooperative relationship with
my parents same turbulent activity but
with a child that I kind of see myself
in
and I've asked them to kind of like lead
me out of that relationship like I just
I can't be there their therapist to talk
about how
my brother treats my parents my parents
treat my brother
and
also kind of seemed like the same trauma
being impacted on a child that I
experienced as a kid gotcha
so in the nerd world we call it
triangulation sounds like you're getting
brought in as
you're being used by the other two
parties as a as fuel to the fire that
they're casting at the other party right
so your parents call you to tell you
about what your brother's doing and your
brother calls you and tells you what
your parents are doing and the whole
time you're watching this little child
just thinking just get at it run run run
run right
yeah in the same behavioral issues from
when I was a kid so it's like oh they're
screaming in the house and they're
fighting over
so how does this how does this impact
you
you said you put up some boundaries in
in your families violating them what
does that mean
so for me it's like hey I can't be your
therapist I don't want to have every
conversation we have the about this
and
when every time that we get together
it's oh why can't you be more involved
with us as a family of the world because
it's toxic and I don't really want to go
back to where I was when I was 12. right
uh are you married do you have kids
uh no okay
um
I guess the question I want to ask you
man if we were just if we were sitting
there in San Antonio sharing a meal I I
would I would
just want to know at 35 why are you
still letting your parents have any
influence in your life whatsoever at all
uh it's more either I have a
relationship with them or don't and it's
accept that accept that
you've been propping up their most them
emotionally for your whole life
and so they don't want a relationship
with you
they want to extract and use you
and so it's not you that's giving up
this relationship it's you that keeps
going into this predatory
they're trying to take your soul like a
Harry Potter dementor
just not a matter of of keeping up the
relationship they have they they have
ended that part
what you have to decide is do I want to
keep showing up in some sort of facade
and some sort of Mirage where we're all
in the same room together even though
I'm not even here because my 12 year old
self recognizes this toxicity and he's
we're just disassociated we checked out
and then I gotta roll my eyes when Dad
starts complaining about brother and
then I gotta stare at the floor when
brother starts complaining about Mom you
see what I'm saying this isn't a
relationship
then I guess like the second question is
like how do I kind of come to terms with
like
letting go of that it really what I've
hoped for it really really hurts
it really really hurts
because it shouldn't be like this
it shouldn't have been like this for a
long long time
and my guess is that you've got a level
of exhaustion running underneath your
machine
because you've been trying to keep this
thing held together for your whole life
and 12 year olds think they can do it by
the time they get to be 35 they realize
they can't but they try anyway
have you sat down in this that this
thing's over
yeah I think I've been kind of like more
than it in a way for tests like
here or so yeah
here's the two big things you got to do
the first thing is
you have to take care of that little boy
it's still working
and you've heard me say this on the show
a million times and I'll say it a
million more
that little 12 year old boy that is
still asking the question at the age of
35.
why won't you just be my dad
why won't you just be my mom
like why do I have to do jump through so
many hoops and do so much work
for y'all to love me
and that kid's
a kid's exhausted
and that's not his job
and so you're gonna have to at some
point whether it's
you get with a therapist and go on a
rabbit hole with Bodywork and all that
kind of stuff or you sit down and for
the next
I don't know 90 days once a week you
write that kid a letter
just say dear 12 year old Carlos
remember that time
fill in the blank
and then brother came home high and dad
hit me hit you that wasn't your fault
that's cause dad
didn't know what he was doing with
brother and brother was out of control
and I'm so sorry that no one was there
to protect you
then the next week dear Carlos remember
that time
I just want you to know
when you become 35 things are going to
be different
and that's the first part of this thing
the second part of this thing I think is
equally if not more challenging
is you're going to have to find new
adult relationships to plug into because
you cannot do Life by yourself
and that's the worst man
are you a pretty lonely guy
uh no I've got a pretty strong friend
group but like chosen family there you
go
um I would even suggest marking that
some sort of event when I say event I
don't mean like renting out a stadium or
something not the Alamodome but I mean
like
having people over and saying like
henceforth y'all are my family
and looking people in the eye and saying
I'm gonna call you at 2AM when things
get sideways and when I start dating
somebody I'm gonna call you and when I
get scared about my future I'm gonna
call you right just just go around the
room but you'll have something that you
can go back and Mark as the moment
um what's your biggest fear about
just stop and return phone calls
relationship it's your only one I've had
my entire life yeah
can you objectively see they left you
yeah yeah
just how unhealthy it's been yeah
for whatever it's worth Carlos you're
worth
relationships that you can pour into
and there's not a bunch of holes in the
bottom of the pitcher and you're worth
relationships that people pour into you
and they don't use you
to prop themselves up but they are with
you because you're they're your friend
but all this angst man how about this
what if you just tried it in a graduated
way
he said hey once a month I'm I'm only
gonna swing by once a month I'm gonna
stay for 30 minutes
by the way let me Circle back real quick
you show me your boundaries like hey
I've told them I don't want to talk
about them all the time I don't talk
about brother all the time or I don't
want to talk always be talking about Mom
and Dad
make your boundaries a little more firm
I will not discuss my brother with you
period when you choose to start talking
about brother I am going to choose to
walk out of the room because you are
telling me you no longer want me in here
by bringing that up
Hey Brother
I refuse to talk about mom and dad with
you anymore I love you we can talk about
you know whatever Sports we're hanging
out whatever I'm not I refuse to talk
about this with you 100 so every time
you bring up Mom and Dad
that's like you saying hey get out of
here Carlos I don't want to talk to you
so
there's that uh make those boundaries
super firm but I would slowly start
um not even slowly I would rather
abruptly start pulling this thing apart
instead of going over there every week
I'm gonna go over once a month and
they're gonna give you the oh you too
good why aren't you coming over anymore
we miss you aren't you ever here
yeah I was hanging out with my buddies
I've got some stuff at work to do I
don't want to be a part of all this
drama and Chaos um because y'all are
y'all are choosing it to be like this
and I'm choosing to not be in this mess
those conversations will be hard and
make no mistake when you have true firms
strong boundaries
people will start trying to smash them
just to knock him down because they're
an affront to other people
um hold firm
oh firm little 12 year old Carlos has
been waiting for this moment for a long
time
and now it's time for 35 year old Carlos
to let that boy go run and play
he's been being adult for way too long
let him go
it's time for you 35 year old Carlos to
say
what am I gonna do now
what am I gonna do next
[Music]
we'll be right back
hey John deloney here I say it all the
time you can't wish your way to a better
life it boils down to being intentional
about what you do every day intentional
acts become healthy habits and one of
the most important things you can do to
improve your mental and physical health
right now starting tonight is to get
enough quality sleep and I know this
from personal experience and for me
great sleep starts with an incredible
mattress and that's why I love dream
Cloud mattresses whether you're a back
sleeper a stomach sleeper or a side
sleeper because your dumb dog is always
in the way dream Cloud's combo of gel
memory foam and coil technology keeps
you cool and comfortable all night long
and right now dream cloud is running
their biggest offer ever 40 off all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings exclusively for my
listeners visit dreamcloudsleep.com and
enter your promo code John deloney
that's dreamcloudsleep.com and promo
code John deloney
all right we are back let's go to L in
Charlotte North Carolina what's up Elle
is it Ellie or l
it's l l very cool that's awesome
it's a beautiful name L you should I
don't know if I was you I would just
have one letter that'd be kind of player
but that's all right so what's up
um
sorry I'm really nervous
uh so I guess my question is like how
how do you make sure that you're 100
sure about someone that you're about to
marry like how do you know that they're
the right person
oh gross do you have one
what do you mean like
are you dating somebody right now and
you're like I don't know I don't know
well
yeah I'm just kidding oh that's awesome
so what's giving you pause what's giving
you pause all right let me let me just
to answer your question there's zero no
chance no way no how there's no such
thing as like 100 it doesn't exist
and I'll also say that the only
marriages that make like the news or the
sensationalist not like you know what I
mean the millions and millions and
millions and millions of people who do
life together with their spouse for
their whole life that that's just not
Sensational news so it doesn't we don't
see those those people
yeah I mean I feel like I've been
listening to your show for a little bit
and and
um
and I mean my my parents are divorced
myself so it's just like I don't I feel
like all I hear about when it comes to
marriage is that you know people hide
things and then they come out later and
then there's just so much heartbreak and
yeah I mean everybody seems to always
ask you know like oh how did I how could
I have seen this before it happened and
things like that and
um
it gives me so much
uh I guess anxiety about it and
um I I feel like I'm just not super
confident in
most of my decisions but probably one of
them
ah man the fact that you are cautious
about making big decisions tells me that
you're very very wise
really yes so here's a couple of my
entry points into this question okay
number one
do we hold similar values and they don't
have to be word for 100 for 100 but do
we hold similar values tightly and do we
hold our beliefs very loosely
I have a value that I will always be
curious
always going to be asking the next
question I think that's really important
I seek out places where I'm wrong
that's of a value
and I like people around me to share
that because it makes my community
humble and
more interested in getting to the right
answer and helping people than defending
themselves
then on top of that value I have a
million different beliefs
and some of them are categorically wrong
they're incorrect some of them I was so
I've I've spoken at Medical School I've
spoken to medical school about 10 years
ago gave this big long lecture on
something about nutrition I can't tell
you how incorrect I was L it's
embarrassing looking back on it I'm just
wrong I was wrong
and so I hold my beliefs very Loosely
and I want the person that I'm going to
be with I want to have similar values
when it comes to Faith maybe we believe
different things but we both believe
we share the value that belief in
something bigger than ourselves is
crucial to our lives cool and then I'm
gonna hold it really Loosely and when my
wife comes in and says I think I
interpret this particular thing this way
I go huh tell me more because I'm not um
tied to you've got to have the same
beliefs that's insane that's why we read
books so we get new beliefs right okay
so values and beliefs that's number one
the other thing that I think the data
suggests is more important is this
how do you come back
from disagreement
from fights when one person gets off the
tracks
um as Steph Curry talks about the the
part of the cycle uh that's called
repair how do y'all repair things do you
pretend it never happened do you scream
and yell and kick do you dissect it do
you somebody want to talk about and talk
about it and talk about it or somebody
want to use it as a weapon to get what
they want in the relationship or do you
both dig in and solve it how are we
going to come back together not if but
when we get sideways
and somewhere along the way in your
parents marriage and I'm just using them
because you brought them up
the repair cycle
was
um they weren't able to reconcile it
or somebody did a thing or somebody was
struggling or somebody had a different
picture for their life when they laid
that picture out
um the other person said well then I'm
out
and so I want to know how we're going to
address problems how we're going to
discuss them and by the way that will
shift and change too
the question is are they going to shift
and change with us so tell me about this
guy you're with
um
he's great
um we do I mean we we've been together
since
um you know like the early like the
first two years of college and then we
stayed together after graduation and
um we had one major breakup
uh my senior year in
after that like uh at least in my
family's eyes
he was I mean he couldn't come back from
it and your family doesn't get a vote
right
but it's really hard to
to you know
you're different you're gonna care and
it's Gonna Hurt it's gonna be painful
and at some point how old are you
I'm 22. yeah it's at some point you're
gonna have to decide I'm being with this
person
and then the adults in your life are
gonna have to choose
um
are they going to be with you or are
they going to choose their their high
horse
and that's that's those are the only two
choices
my wife and I broke up five times
over the course of five years maybe four
and a half times
and then we've almost broken up several
times over the 20 years we've been
married it's hard
it's messy
but when things look grim and when
they'll like when it looks like there's
so much smoke I can't see forward
one of us always says I'm going back to
the table I hope you'll join me
because that's one of our values is you
always go back to the table
go ahead so sorry I was just gonna say I
wish that people would
um
be more honest about that aspect of
relationships because we do
I mean it's gotten better but we do tend
to bicker a lot and you know we have
disagreements and we get pretty upset
but you know people since we've been
together have always told us like oh you
know this this you shouldn't be together
I mean it just shouldn't be that way and
I mean
it's discouraging and it makes me have
the impression that you know your
relationship is always supposed to be
perfect and you know ever
yeah there's just no such thing
and let's be super clear our
um
I'm a very good sophisticated fighter I
don't do a lot of bickering
but I've got some pretty nasty
conversations that I have in my head
that nobody ever hears
right so my body's at war with my wife
even though she doesn't even know she's
just over there like doing her thing
doesn't even know we're in a fight and
vice versa at least you guys are saying
it out loud
what I would want to get to is beneath
that
what is what is the bickering for
well currently we're long distance okay
and that's been pretty tough because
very very hard it's just hard to
um you know like communicate wants and
needs and you know
I think insecure
and are you kidding me they come in like
they come in like a military invasion
yes so how long are y'all planning on
doing this long distance
um hopefully not much longer
um make a choice
so well he's he's active duty so he
needs to finish school before he can
move with me but that's going to be
another
talking all tough and you're like he's
active duty and so I'm super wrong see
there I am I'm wrong again
um here's here's the hardest part about
a relationship okay I think
the hardest part is it only works if you
go all in
a marriage only works if you go all in
and
if you go all in you can get hurt really
really bad
but if you try to hedge your bet you try
to put one foot in one foot out all your
feet both feet in but just a few toes
out
it's gonna fail
it'll fail every time
you gotta go or it may not fail
spectacularly in some big catastrophic
implosion
but you'll end up like millions and
millions and millions of people across
our country where you're just roommates
you know you're good co-managers of your
house but you're not in a relation
you're not all in
y'all sleep together twice a month I
mean it's whatever like but you're not
all in
so the greatest advice I could give you
is
if you're gonna go go all in pack up and
move
like to quote the great Good Will
Hunting go see about a girl go see about
a guy
go all in
and just know the only way this thing
works is by going all in and man you are
opening yourself up for a heartache that
is unfathomably painful
and relationships ultimately ultimately
become
me looking across the table at my wife
in the eyes and saying
I'm going to give you everything
please don't hurt me
I'm going to tell you everything
please don't use it against me
I'm going to show you my soul
please see it and love me anyway
and she says the same thing back
and L just saying that out loud is scary
hearing that is that scary
that's it
so are you in
I would like to ideally say that I am
it's just I'm scared
I'm scared also of like
just being alone in the end if it
doesn't work out because you're alone
right now a lot of times you're alone
right now
you're alone with somebody right next to
you
what does that mean that means you're
living parallel lives with somebody
who's become a little bit more than a
figment of your imagination because
y'all are doing this thing long distance
and you're insecure and you're doubtful
and you're unanchored
and he is too
and so this idea like I'm just gonna end
up alone people sacrifice deep love for
for partnership for somebody sitting on
it like next to you for proximity
do you know what I'm saying
yeah
you're worth more than halfway
and he is too quite frankly
I would love to see what happens in this
thing if you go all in
and I think it's perfectly fair to say I
say these words in my marriage so
I'm scared that I'm gonna put all my
cards on the table and you're gonna
cash out and leave
and that's scary
and the only way this thing works is to
push all your chips in that's why I tell
people to share a banking account that's
why I tell people to be honest with each
other and not keep secrets not be a
and over share but don't keep
secrets
that's why I tell people
hold the other person very very loosely
because they're a human they're gonna
breathe and they're gonna fail and
they're gonna have new thoughts and new
imaginations and want to go down new
rabbit holes
your job isn't to squeeze them so tight
that everybody stays connected nah man
it's to be incomplete and total trust
and love and vulnerability the whole
thing
go all in L go all in here's what I
think I think you really like this guy I
think you love this guy
and I think you've got enough voices
around you I think you've got enough uh
personal experiences around you
that tell you that
going all in that type of love is not
safe and it's not wise
and your body's probably right because
you've seen people get hurt
Choice you're gonna have to make for
yourself is am I going to do it anyway
and I'll tell you in my life it's made
all the difference
all
we'll be right back
all right let's go out to Kyle in Boise
Idaho what's up Kyle
ah not too much how are you John I'm
doing good man not too much not too much
what's up man
um so
um just quick question of
kind of
I've been with this girl for about three
years
um I don't know if I should leave
um
it's been
it's been good but
it's wanna sorry I'm nervous it's like
it's been fine
[Laughter]
so
he has
um she has mental and physical health
problems okay I've always been there for
them and
I've never had a problem with any of
that
but over the last year or so she's been
very controlling
to a point where I'm not allowed to go
see my family until she can see her
family and we all both of our families
live in different states
so it's kind of hard to see either one
of them but
we try to make it out whenever we can
um it also goes as far as I'm not
allowed to hang out with friends because
she doesn't have her family or her
friends in the state
[Music]
that's hard man I'm sorry
um
are y'all married
uh we are not we've been dating for
three years okay
the easy flipping answer for me is this
um the purpose of dating is get to know
somebody
and get to practice safety and get to
practice compatibility get to practice
intimacy
and over the last 36 months you have
come to realize I don't want this life
mm-hmm
I don't want somebody who a is going to
be so utterly controlling in a way that
makes it no logical or rational sense
right this is different if you call me
and be like I just want to go to the bar
do we only go four nights a week and she
wants me home with her I would say
you're you're a right that's not
the case here right this is no this is
um
power and control
the other side of the coin here is if
you got somebody who you love who's
struggling with mental health issues and
physical issues and is not doing
everything they can in their power to go
get well to do the things they need to
do to be whole
okay then they're ultimately making a
choice for the type of relationship they
want to have so let me take anxiety for
example I'm never gonna blame anybody
for having anxiety that's your body's
response is trying to take care of you
right and anxiety looks like all
different kinds of things to all
different kind of people
but I will hold you accountable for
going to get the help you need
yeah see what I'm saying and so yeah if
I step back and I I'm pretty uh this
will sound really cold okay but if I
step back you're in relationship with
somebody
who um
has
doesn't appear to be interested in doing
the hard hard work to be as well as
possible
and who is more interested in
slowly exerting more and more power and
control over the one person
in her geographical area that's trying
to love her and take care of her
right
so um what does it look like if you if
you broke up okay
so let's do that thought added on to
that I I don't want to be morbid about
this by any means but we have a the only
loan I have and I'm trying to get rid of
but we have an auto loan in both of our
names
how much um I am primary on it um how
much is 30 000.
sell the car dude
but
my thing is she doesn't want to sell it
she's the she's another thing that we
disagree about is our spending and
but I want to sell it I want to get
basically I'm all in on the Ramsey thing
where I want to get out of debt I don't
like owing people money yeah in general
I don't either so yeah so here's the
thing man don't let this is a
to quote quote Jocko this is this is a
non-factor
okay okay give her the car and pay it
off and
um to quote Dave Ramsey it's just a
thirty thousand dollar stupid tax
oh man I got an auto loan with a
girlfriend that was dumb
right and I put both of our name on the
title I was dumb
that's all right
30 000 bucks
okay it's less expensive than a divorce
three years from now
true right
ultimately ultimately here's the deal
I'm not gonna tell you to leave I'm not
gonna take a breakup I'm not gonna tell
you doing those things what I am going
to tell you is you get to decide what
your life looks like
right and you get to decide beyond what
it looks like in terms of the size of
the house or size of car something like
that you get to decide the
the warmth and the air inside of your
home is it electric and charged and
chaotic or is coming home a place of
Peace both you and the person you mayor
get to choose that
and we get so lost with our Diagnostics
and our this is and I've got this and
this happened to me cool
I get to walk in my front door and
decide how this place is going to be
and I'm gonna work every plan I can come
up with I'm gonna do everything I can
to create that space and then you look
at the person you're thinking about
marrying and saying well you create that
space with me
and the hard part is what you're telling
me is she has said no I'm good
I'm gonna do what I want to do when I
want to do it and by the way so are
freaking you you are too
a little bit but or a lot or a lot
you're saying that it makes me think I I
do come home and have to walk on
eggshells a lot of houses after your
house
so it's your house I wish more people
would reverse engineer their life in
that way
because
um not owing anybody any money that's a
big deal for me that sets off a lot of
childhood triggers with money issues
growing up
um not owing anybody any money when I
walk in the front door there's never
gonna be a bill on my kitchen table
that uh
sends me off into the woods right this
sends my that my 10 year old self has to
come out and try to sword fight and
defend for me
it's never gonna be there I don't owe
anybody money and so
for me the reason I don't owe anybody
any money is so I can walk in my house
and drop my shoulders I'm home
the reason I go to marriage counseling
the reason I go to counseling the reason
I am constantly trying to become a
better dad is I want to walk home and I
can't wait to to meet my kids because my
wife and I have worked really hard to
create to create an environment where we
like our kids and they like being around
us right see what I'm saying all this
comes back to
I just want to walk in and drop my
shoulders I can do that in a
1400 square foot house and I can do that
in a 2500 square foot house or whatever
like this the particulars for me matter
less than
I just want to start for peace and I
want to solve for freedom and I want to
solve for
the same with clutter that same stuff
with crazy filled calendars all that
stuff works together
and so ask yourself
after three years of being together
like she seems to be pretty clear on the
kind of life she wants to have which is
whatever she wants whenever she wants it
okay come come hell or high water come
anxiety come come stress come
frustration come fight come a sad
frustrated uh spouse none of that
matters I get what I want what I want
mm-hmm
I miss telling you brother you are worth
peace
thank you
and Ash is up to you man I I know I'm
being Cavalier here and almost almost
clinical it's kind of cold
I understand how hard the decisions you
have to make moving forward are I get
that
very very tough very tough
it's not like you're just gonna Waltz in
today and be like all right we're
breaking up you have a great one I know
it's way more complex than that and
it's way way more complex
so I'm not gonna tell you to go do that
I'm gonna tell you is
seek peace
seek freedom
seek
life when after you're out slaying
dragons all day and you're working your
butt off at your job
trying to navigate this Wackadoo culture
we have
one safe place
and then you look at that person you're
gonna marry and say will you create a
safe place with me
and now you're talking
that's Legacy changing my friend and
she'll call Kyle we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right hey that wraps up the show and
we're not doing lyrics today we're gonna
do something a little bit different
we'll do something a little bit
different
um
this is from the good news movement
Instagram site that Kelly gave me and
I've got Kelly's phone right now we
could get off the rails but I won't
check this out this past weekend was the
10th anniversary of the Boston Marathon
bombing
and
here's what the so they ran the marathon
and there's lots of amazing stories that
come out of this but I just wanted to
pass along some really extraordinary
news about some extraordinary people
says 10 years after the tragic bombings
that killed eight-year-old Martin
Richard
ah dang it I'm gonna kill
I'm gonna start crying hold on
Ten Years After the tragic bombings that
killed eight-year-old Martin Richard his
Elementary School classmates now have
legal age to run the marathon completed
an emotional marathon in honor of their
beloved childhood friend
joining them were friends neighbors and
family including Martin's older brother
who completed the marathon as well
all of them were eight years old small
children in third grade when the tragedy
unfolded Ten Years Later these memories
will animate their experiences
ten years
his friends
thought and stayed connected and
remembered their body
talk about making meaning
we're gonna go run for our buddy
and everybody came back together
that's an amazing story
it does not get much cooler than that
so Kelly I I don't know how to do it
without lyrics I guess we just wrap it
up well Andrew has something he wants to
say
well yeah so I just kind of lost words
earlier
dude you don't
have to say thank you oh you're welcome
thank you thank you for saving all of
our jobs oh yeah that's right and being
a good friend you're my good friend
you're one of my few friends that live
in my uh
I was gonna my special little
neighborhood yeah our our area of
Greater Nashville there we go that's a
much nicer Wes and Steven also uh
pitched in for something else yes free
to us dude one of the best guys in the
world surrounded by great people it's
awesome and it's mostly because of this
show so thank you awesome you got it
brother thank you guys hey everybody
listening go do something nice for
somebody
take care
[Music]